Depuis le début des temps, nous nous sommes
demandé comment l'univers en est venu à être un
plan glorieusement orchestré ou
quelque chose de beaucoup plus stupide
tu es le vent sous ma fuite les
algues de mon œil
seras-tu mon compagnon pour la vie je
romps avec toi
et  au fait tu ne ressembles en rien à
ta photo de profil cette année pour la
fille de mes rêves notre vingtième Century
Fox présente
oh bonjour les mammifères mais qu'est ce que tu fais
ici ça ne fait que commencer
la mère de tous les astéroïdes rêvant
vers nous on va chercher des indices
Manny le  Diego buck and scratch cela vous
dérange
le cours de collision de l'ère glaciaire ralentissant
oui c'est définitivement fini